all right turning now to a topic on the
minds of many parents at home the
importance of inclusion in children's
books how kids are represented can
inspire children to place themselves in
a story and that can enable them to see
themselves as the hero of their own
story adriana diaz has the story now of
one mom who made it her mission to make
sure kids from all races religions and
families could find books featuring
characters like them
they say never judge a book by its cover
as you can see it's a rainbow but it's
the covers at this chicago children's
store that move people we get a lot of
gasps from children really we do we've
had parents and adults cry that's
because at kiddo the faces on the books
are black and brown and protagonists you
don't usually see
a girl in a wheelchair a mom in a hijab
those are deliberate choices says kiddo
owner kiwan nurula we want every kid to
feel reflected to feel seen to feel
included kids with disabilities kids who
are growing up in foster care or have
been adopted or whose parents are going
through a divorce with titles like queer
heroes hair love and the abcs of black
history
books that celebrate aztec heroes and
chicana ones what do you think of these
books
they're beautiful and i don't like them
they all have different lessons to be
learned in each book
so it's really nice beeswax crayons that
show
wow the different skin shapes oh i wish
i had these growing up we talked about
coming over these regulars
introduced us to come for the stores
inclusivity and community ryan has two
beautiful brilliant mothers and we have
an
exceptional daughter and so we want her
to be represented in the books that she
sees for people who say you know to play
devil's advocate that there's too much
focus on race these days what do you say
to them
easy for you to say
you know it's just like
why women women's history month why not
men's history month you know the reason
we need these things is because there's
a deficit nurla got into this work as a
new mom she struggled to find clothes
that reflected her family so she started
designing her own onesies like this one
and an entrepreneur was born i was
really excited about that do you have a
business background not at all
not at all
her background is on stage
you've embodied the idea of diversity in
characters that you played in the past
you know where i'm getting well
um
i'm a retired princess disney princess
if you ever wanted to know what happens
to them when they grow old when they
grow up
yeah when the princess and the frog came
out i was one of the princesses in the
show at disneyland
i think even in my performing career
you're always thinking about your
representation on stage and what that
could mean for a little kid who wants to
sing and dance too hey your total is but
business is in her blood too
stretching back to her great grandfather
simeon neil senior was a tailor and he
had a family in tulsa oklahoma he had a
tailor shop on black wall street and his
family was forced to flee
during the massacre of 1921.
according to oral history a customer
helps the family escape hiding them
under hay on a wagon and so they made it
on their journey to chicago
and thankfully he was able to
reopen his tailor shop on the south side
how does that feel being this extension
of this entrepreneurial spirit in your
family when i was growing up um
i knew this part of my history but no
one else did we didn't learn about it in
school the fact that my
great-grandfather had a business on
black wall street is special you know
it's unique it's you know that's like
black royalty almost and i do try to
uplift his legacy and you know live up
to that foundation that legacy lives on
here inspiring future generations to
thrive just as they are we don't want
any child to feel isolated in their
experience we want them to come into the
kiddo store and say
oh wait like i'm not the only one
and when books have heroes of all
backgrounds real world heroes are born
for cbs mornings adriana diaz chicago
go kiwa and thank you that's such an
important thing you're doing there